وفي التطورات الميدانيه تتغير المعادله
وتتغير هنا نتحدث كل ساعه على هذا النحو
باتت تسير حسابات الحرف في اوكرانيا
تقديرات اوروبيه ترجح دخول الحرب مرحله
خطيره في ظل ازدياد احتياجات كياب للصمود
وحشد الروس ل 300 الف مقاتل لشن هجوم
الوشي نداءات الرئيس الاوكرانيه فولودي
باستعجال مد بلاده بالذخيره التي واشكت
على النفاذ سرعان ملاقت استجابه واسعه اما
ميدانيا مشاهدينا في القرن اقرت موسكو
بوقوع حادث استهداف شحنه من صواريخ كروز
الروسيه من طراز كاليبر اثناء نقلها عبر
السكك الحديديه في منطقه جنكو شمال شبه
جزيره القرد وفي بخموت المعركه تحتدم اكثر
اذ يتبادل الطرفان القصف والاتهامات في
محاوله لتغيير المعادله على الارض مع
التعهد كل منهما حسم المعركه اما في
دنياسك شرقي اوكرانيا المعركه لا تقل حده
عن بخموت اذ اسفل القصف الروسيه عن مقتل
مدنيين اثنين على الاقل واصابه ثلاثه
اخرين خلال الاربع والعشرين الساعه
الماضيه